[Musik]
breaking news hier bei bild und es geht
wieder um clans schauplatz ein
fitnessstudio in berlin und hier soll
heute mitten in der nacht ein mann
erstochen worden sein und dabei handelt
es sich nicht um irgendwen sondern um
den sohn des kleinbusses ist was ist
passiert feuerwehr und polizei rückten
heute nacht um 2 uhr aus zum
fitnessstudio sie finden den schwer
verletzten mann er wird nur von einem
notarzt versorgt und dann direkt ins
krankenhaus gebracht der täter kann zwar
flüchten wird aber von den videokameras
gefilmt sprechen wir darüber bei uns im
studio christin war christin weiß man
mittlerweile schon mehr wie das ganze
zustande gekommen ist wie das ganze
passiert ist
nein weiß man aktuell noch nicht also
die tat ist wie du es schon gesagt hast
in der nacht zu heute passiert vor einem
fitnessstudio in prenzlauer berg es
liegt zehn minuten zehn autominuten hier
von uns entfernt noch weiß man nichts
man weiß aber dass die tat angeblich von
videokameras gefilmt worden sind ich
gehe davon aus dass die polizei die
ermittlungen jetzt auf nimmt aber wir
stehen jetzt noch ganz am anfang die
videoaufnahmen müssen jetzt ausgewertet
werden man muss schauen ob überhaupt
verwendbares material darauf zu finden
ist um dann eventuell die mutmaßlichen
täter der den sohn von isa remo dort
niedergestochen hat zu finden gegen zwei
uhr nachts ist das ganze ja passiert ein
notarzt ist noch zum tatort gerufen
worden hat versucht ihn zu reanimieren
jetzt hat man einen täter sogar einen
mutmaßlichen täter festgenommen ist das
richtig
diese informationen dazu habe ich
tatsächlich noch gar keine information
ich glaube die polizei wird jetzt schaut
jetzt auch erstmal ist das überhaupt
sicherlich gibt es in einer anderen
denen sie vielleicht schon mal
festgenommen haben den werden sie jetzt
auch befragen ob überhaupt im
zusammenhang mit der mit der tat steht
aber zum jetzigen zeitpunkt ist mir
persönlich tatsächlich noch kein
täter bekannt die man auch wirklich
diese tat zu schreiben kann also der
sohn jetzt im krankenhaus nachdem er
niedergestochen wurde erzähle uns ein
bisschen was über den remo clan über das
clan oberhaupt ist er sehr bekannt sehr
berüchtigt
also eine tat es ist nicht die erste tat
in dieser art die hier in berlin
geschieht also wir erinnern uns im april
ende april 20 20 22 jetzt zu ostern als
ein anderer bekanntes clan mitglied aus
einer anderen familie tödlich
niedergestochen wurde auf einem
volksfest hier in berlin das ist typisch
auch für die kleinsten solche attacken
passieren es geht hier um
parallelgesellschaft das ist eine
demonstration von macht das heißt wir
machen unsere eigenen regeln wir machen
unsere eigenen gesetze und
das zeigen wir auch offen und das machen
wir auch auf der offenen straße und
diese tat jetzt von gestern nacht oder
von heute nacht zeigt dass und
demonstriert dass auf jeden fall und der
renault clan ist kein unbekannter klaren
und in israel
der sohn von isa ist auch kein
unbekannter es gab vor ein paar jahren
2017 gab es eine attacke wo es mail
angeblich mit dabei sein soll gewesen
sein sollte auf einen konkurrierenden
clan
bei der vsg ging es geht darum die
familie dort soll sich isa damals
angeblich geld geborgt haben für die
villa in buckow um sie zu bezahlen um
sie zu kaufen und angeblich wollte das
mitglied der familie das geld
wiederhaben
und da war man sich dann aber wohl
wollte man das wohl auch nicht
zurückzahlen und dann wurde angeblich
auch israel dort hingeschickt und
ja der mann wurde mit einem
baseballschläger
getötet die tat konnte ihm aber nie
nachgewiesen werden es gab einen riesen
mammutprozess danach aber es fehlten
einfach die beweise und israel wurde
freigesprochen vielleicht hat das
irgendwas mit dieser tat jetzt heute
heute in der nacht heute morgen zu tun
vielleicht ist es eine art racheakt aber
das sind alles spekulationen die sich zu
diesem zeitpunkt einfach noch nicht
bestätigen lassen sobald mehr
hintergründe zu der tat von heute nacht
bekannt werden wenn man das von dir
erfahren vielen dank für den moment an
unserem bild reporterin und klaren
expertin christine wahl